I've talked a lot about
anti-intellectualism
and pseudo-intellectual ISM on the right
pseudo-intellectual ISM is people who
think that they're informed because they
read the books of Sophists like Mark
Levin and Laura Ingraham as if those
people are intellectuals and that's very
dangerous because they actually think
they know stuff about what's going on
and the things the very serious things
that exist in the world to quote our
president also damaging is anti
intellectualism and when I talk about
anti intellectualism I often talk about
this movement on the right which is kind
of writing off the value and importance
of college by saying a higher education
it's liberal indoctrination combined
with safe spaces and trigger warnings or
whatever this has now been measured by a
new Pew Research Center poll and this
campaign by the right has worked
incredibly well this is a poll done by
the Pew Research Center which looks at
public opinion about a variety of
institutions and one of those
institutions that they look at is
colleges and universities and for the
first time if you're watching if you're
looking at this graph that we have up on
the screen this is the furthest right
element colleges and universities for
the first time a majority of Republicans
see college as more bad than good as
more negative than positive and not
surprisingly next to that you'll see
that left-leaning Americans don't agree
72% of left-leaning Americans believe
that colleges and universities are a
good thing these numbers are very
different from two years ago two years
ago 54% of Republicans said colleges and
universities are generally good now
that's already shockingly low right
that's basically one out of two and now
you've seen a significant change a
majority of Republicans now basically
think college and university is bad we
knew this was going on Pat but until I
saw this data I didn't realize how
effective the anti college campaign on
the right has been well I think a lot of
it has to do with this safe space
snowflake type mantra that's been
happening over the past couple of years
but when people actually think
critically of this I think
they would be of course in support of
the academics because you know you want
your doctors and your lawyers to be
educated you want your engineers and
your architects to be educated I think
people are just ill informed on this
well there's it's not only that but
there's also I think an idea that hey
listen this is the United States the
United States is the place for the great
education in the US has always valued
education that's not true that is
actually not true Noam Chomsky once said
quote but I think that there are things
about the United States that aren't
really recognized sufficiently so it's
important to remember that until 1945
the United States was a cultural
backwater it wasn't part of the modern
world so a good part of the country is
still adhering to what's been
traditional it's just not part of the
modern world just take a look at the
statistics the religious fanaticism
there's just nothing like it in the
world well there is but it's not
countries that we usually compare
ourselves to Chomsky goes on I mean one
of the problems with getting people
interested in global warming is that
about 40% of the population thinks Jesus
is coming in 2050 so who cares the great
science fiction writer Isaac Asimov has
also commented about this who said quote
there is a cult of ignorance in the
United States and there always has been
the strain of anti-intellectualism has
been a constant thread winding its way
through our political and cultural life
nurtured by the false notion that
democracy means that my ignorance is
just as good as your knowledge remember
the kids in middle school and high
school who thought it was lame to know
stuff and that it was cool not to care
about learning anything or even having
any clue what the teacher was talking
about they're now running the country
that movie Revenge of the Nerds I don't
know if you're familiar with that movie
Pat it's Revenge of the morons now where
there is this pride in in saying we
reject knowledge we reject enlightenment
and this is actually an issue of
national security and economics if you
reject college because of liberal
indoctrination and safe spaces or
whatever
then there are people from other
countries that value education more that
are going to get your jobs that actually
is a way in which foreigners will get
your jobs if you choose to be ignorant
and unqualified national security if you
start lacking in education then other
countries are going to have the people
who can develop the technologies to
basically dominate the United States
when it comes to national security
people that laugh this off is snowflakes
a safe space
trigger warning liberal indoctrination
Rick Santorum's name comes to mind
you're putting the country you claim to
love at risk it just seems as if we were
leaving up the most important tasks to
those who are the least qualified and
not even just least qualified but the
ones that just don't even care that's
exactly right and that is why you know
both pseudo-intellectual ISM and anti
intellectualism are incredibly damaging
for different ways and in different
industries and in different areas of
life but this is a real problem and the
idea that merely by being conservative
you're going to avoid the problems
caused by whatever you see is the
weights on society it's a joke folks it
is an absolute and total joke discuss
this with us on reddit david pakman.com
slash re d di t today's program is made
possible in part by taga dev the hosting
specialist they host websites for
everybody from bloggers to businesses to
financial traders you can get virtual
dedicated and private server solutions
cloud server solutions custom server
solutions whatever is right for your
project or business is available at taga
Deb and with a growing number of people
increasingly interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga Deb is offering our viewers and
listeners a twenty British pound free
credit when you sign up to give you a
chance to try out their cloud server
solution this is a limited availability
offer first-come first-served for
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to signup tag
adhikam forward slash
DPS and use the discount code TV PS 20
during your account registration 20
British pounds roughly 23 24 US dollars
once again check it out
sign up tag adapt calm /td PS the
discount code is TDPS 20